The first question, the best-case running time for a given input size is no longer
than the best measured time for each algorithm.
This is true and to think about this, all you really need to do is realize that our definition--
the best-case running time is better than all other possible running time.
If there's one smaller than it, well, it's not really the best is it, and you can think
of the same thing for the worst-case running time to the second one, which is also true.
The worst-case running time for given input size is at least the worst measured time for each algorithm
because if there is a worst or longer measured time, then the worst-case running time--
well then it's not worst is it.
Now, for the third question, algorithm beta is the fastest for all inputs.
This is actually false, and even though it's actually true for all of the inputs that we tested,
it might not be true for much smaller inputs--for example, n=1 or 2.
We can't say that it's the fastest for all inputs because well we haven't tested it on all inputs.
It might very well be the case but in order to say that we'll actually
need to test it and that's not really feasible.
And for the final question, what else can for smaller inputs the algorithm with exponential behavior
is faster than the algorithm with polynomial behavior, and this is actually true.
If you got alpha and gamma, alpha being the exponential algorithm and gamma being
the polynomial one, actually is faster--25 minutes is quite a bit faster than 500.
So this is actually true and it's interesting to see that sometimes for small inputs
and exponential algorithm isn't really that big of a deal.